en la ola de violencia que es el estado
en el salvador es una campaña orquestada
de los grupos criminales enseñados en
provocar al gobierno
de modificar el señor dispositiva que el
país está construyendo un modelo en el
combate al tribunal un modelo en el
combate a la delincuencia con nivel
punto de referencia que es en este
momento alcanzando va a ser solucionado
nos convertimos en
[Música]
dos
grupos generando esta ola de violencia
la reacción del estado
me gustan los sectores productivos en
los sectores laborales académicos
religiosos constructivos
por éstas
pero defensores de los derechos humanos
entendemos la preocupación que tienen
les podemos decir que no ha habido un
solo deporte en las violaciones de
derechos humanos ni de manera individual
de colectiva para ciudadanos o para
ciudades
actuando y trabajando conforme a la ley